( applause )
As a kid I used to
dream about the oceans.
It was this wild place
full of color and life.
Home to these alien-looking
fantastical creatures.
I pictured massive sharks
ruling the food chain
and graceful sea turtles
dancing across coral reefs.
As a marine biologist
turned photographer,
I've spent most of my
career looking for places
as magical as those I used to
dream about when I was little.
And it's this
journey that
I wish to share with
you all this evening.
( audience laughter )
So, one of the
most common
questions I receive
from people is,
"What is the most terrifying
moment of your career?"
Now, being in my
shoes at this moment
must be really,
really, really scary.
And, you know, I'll be
honest, I am scared.
I'm scared of over-exposing
-I'm scared of under-exposing
-( audience laughter )
I'm scared of getting
the sharks out of focus
and I'm scared that
my editors are
not going to like a single
picture that I'm taking.
The sharks...
they are probably the least
of my concern right now.
And, you know, remember
these are pretty small sharks
six foot at the most.
So, if sharks are not the
scariest part of my job,
well, what is?
There's one creature
that if it congregates
in large enough numbers, it
scares the crap out of me.
And this is what these
creatures look like.
( audience roaring
with laughter )
The scariest moments of
my photographic career
are without a camera, on a stage
looking over an ocean of people.
You know, give me a white shark
or a Sharknado any
day of the week.
( audience laughter )
But I'm getting ahead of myself
here, way ahead of myself.
And like with any good story,
I think we have to begin
right at the beginning.
Now I began exploring bodies of
water at a fairly young age.
-( audience laughter )
-Hey!
They were a lot smaller than
the ones I explore now
but at that stage, I
thought, you know
they were probably
as exciting as
the Indian Ocean and the Pacific
Ocean are for me today.
Let's fast forward.
Today my photography is largely
anchored in conservation.
And, you know, with
conservation photography
you have two approaches.
I call it "the carrot and
the stick" approach.
On the one hand, you
can showcase them
the most amazing places on this
planet and make them go, "Wow!"
I could not believe
a place like
St. Joseph Atoll
could exist.
And hopefully they make
a connection with it.
So, for half the year,
I have this incredible
privilege to document
some of the most amazing
marine realms on our planet.
However as a
photojournalist,
I need to document the reality
of our relationship
with the oceans.
So, for the other half of
the year, I document, what I
sort of call the darker side
of our relationship
with the sea.
Whether it's over-fishing
the impacts of climate
change or oil-spills.
But I always feel like I
walk a very fine line
between inspiring
and disturbing.
When young photographers
always ask me,
"What is, sort of, number
one tip you can give me?"
I always say, "Begin
in your backyard."
Begin with a subject
and a place that
you are intimately
familiar with
and a place that you can go back
to again and again and again.
In South Africa, I had a
pretty sexy backyard.
I mean, I was lucky.
And my first, sort of, real
reportage story was about
great white sharks.
You know, 12 years ago, I
mean, when I shot this
this was the, sort of,
standard white shark image.
You know, focus on the teeth,
aggressive, dangerous, wild and
these sort of pictures
are easy to take.
However, the more time I
spent out at sea with them
the less I felt that that
picture was accurate.
Instead of the aggressive, you
know, dangerous white shark,
I was seeing an inquisitive, and
very often, curious creature.
The image that follows
is the one picture
that I think best represents
the white shark to me.
And this was taken on one of
those wonderful winter days
the water was clear, the
sea was calm and you know
this white shark came across
this little box-jellyfish.
And, I thought
it would either
swim through it
or just ignore it
and for a few seconds this white
shark actually almost hovered.
As if it was transfixed by
the light on the tentacle
and it just kinda, you
know, hovered there
and just looked,
as if going
"Hello, what are you?"
And, you know, after she had
satisfied her curiosity
that's a three and half
year female by the way
she just kind of, you
know, turned back
and went back into the depths.
And that is, sort of,
how I know great whites,
not with the images before.
My next reportage was also
in Southern Africa again.
But the focus here
is on sardines.
Now, sardines are
a cold water fish
and they prefer the
west and south coast
where the water
is colder.
However, once a year
something unusual happens.
We have this warm current
on the east coast
called the Agulhas current.
And, once a year it
kind of moves offshore.
And these sardines migrate with
this cold water northwards.
And we call this
the "sardine run".
And, you know, sardines, heavily
over-fished over the years
and this is a
species that
really needs the
conservation attention but
everyone thinks it
lives in tin cans.
It's not just the fishing fleets
that follow these sardines.
There's a whole
suite of predators
that follows
them as well.
Common dolphins,
they carve
smaller pieces of sardines
off the massive shoals
and they pin and herd
them up to the surface.
And, you know,
there they form
the holy grail for
all photographers.
The bait ball.
I've done the run for eight
years. I've seen three.
So, the dolphins
herd the sardines
and they take turns, you
know, one after the other
they'll rush in grab a
sardine and swim out
and take turns like that
amazing cooperative
behavior there.
But for me, sardine run
it's all about sharks.
Now, when there's no dolphins,
these sharks
have a really hard time.
They get sardine donuts,
as we call them.
Mouths full of water
most of the time.
When the dolphins
are there
the sardines tend to be herded
together much more closely.
Working with sharks on the run
is a little bit spicy at times.
Especially, at the end when
there's very few sardines left
they treat you like
another shark.
So, you get bumped and hit
probably every ten-seconds.
And if you want to
get good pictures
you just have to ignore the
sharks knocking into you.
Most of the time I know
I'm not on the menu.
These sharks feed
on small sardines.
But I had two encounters,
one, I had a large dusky
shark rip-off my fin
and swim away with it.
What's that all about?
Why does that shark
need another fin, I...
( audience laughter )
I have no idea.
And then another one, I had
two bronze whaler sharks
each hanging on to my
underwater strobes
and I felt like a
Ukrainian weight-lifter.
-( audience laughter )
-I was trying to punch...
They obviously like,
when the strobe recycles
there seems to be an
electro-current that kind of
you know, gets
pushed out, so they
they love biting
on those things.
This is my favorite
sardine run photograph.
For two reasons. One,
it was in clear water
and you know, it looks like the
shark is inhaling the sardines.
And right after
this, he basically
swings around and
comes at me.
You can see these little sardine
heads and tails sticking out
it's like an
over-stuffed suitcase
with the clothes
hanging out.
That's what that reminded me
of, it's just one of those
you know, interesting
visual scenes there.
But, yeah, you know,
that's one of those images
you know, once every eight
years, if you're lucky.
At the end of the,
you know, bait ball
when there's few sardines
left, where do they wanna go?
In between your legs, under
your arms, around your head.
The sardines are seeking
shelter around you.
( audience laughter )
Which is a really,
really bad place to be
not just because
of the sharks.
And there's actually a
bigger danger on the run.
I'm photographing and I'm
looking at screen at something
and as I look up, all
the predators are gone.
You know, it's just
me and the sardines
and we're looking
at each other going,
"What just happened?"
You know, they're too stunned
to actually swim away
'cause they don't
know what's going on.
That just doesn't happen.
Instinct kicks in and I go,
"I'm going where they've gone."
I am back-paddling, I'm swimming
out of the bait ball and...
this guy comes rocketing
out of nowhere.
-( audience gasping )
-It's a Bryde's whale, and...
He comes up and
he pretty much
in front of me, swallows
the entire bait ball.
-( audience laughter )
-All. Done.
I'm probably a foot or two away
and as he does that
he arches upwards
and then he pretty much
just leaves the water.
I mean, they have
all this energy
and he leaps out
of the water
two-thirds come up and
I am, more or less
right at the left where the
sardine is leaping out.
And...
I'm going, "Oh, crap..."
So, I curl into this little ball
and I'm waiting for the sound
of hearing my own bones break.
But I've been trained well.
-I'm still shooting.
-( audience laughter )
And the next picture I
have no recollection.
I have no memory,
but I have this.
( audience gasping )
So, this is all the
water streaming
out of the Bryde's
whale's mouth.
And, I don't remember this.
Somebody else could
have taken this.
It was in my camera at
the end of the day.
It's very hard to see,
you know, in stills.
So this is sort of, some video
of a colleague of mine.
You get the idea
of the whole...
how quick and how crazy
that bait ball actually is.
Imagine trying to get
still pictures in that.
And you have to be where
those sharks are.
You have to be one of those
sharks, to get the pictures.
So, it gets a bit
crazy at times but...
And this is where the
birds are just, you know
-using their wings and...
-( audience laughter )
Couple of sharks.
( music )
And here comes the
Bryde's whale.
( music )
So, now you get
an idea, sort of,
what your environment
is like.
And you sort of just have to...
have to just, you know
forget about all that stuff and
just focus on the task at hand
which is getting great images.